to start with the viewport on the phone
is about 320 pixels which is 640 / - for
the phablet or the phone tablet anything
around about 300 is going to be accepted
sometimes device manufacturers fudge the
numbers just a little bit which is going
to give you fractions so anything around
300 fine the tablets pretty easy its
device pixel ratio is 1 which means that
it's viewport is the same size as its
width so 1024 pixels and same thing for
the laptop with the device pixel ratio
of 1 and a browser width of 800 pixels
you'll get a viewport width of 800
pixels notice on the laptop that the
whole screen is larger than the browser
but the viewport is only about the
browser's with not the whole screen so
it's just 800 pixels